what's going on guys this is rob and as
you all know top five tuesdays are the
days where by we create top five list
based on Marvel and DC we list top five
characters teams concepts so on and so
forth well normally I choose what the
top five list is going to be this week
you guys are choosing what I've done is
I've created topics in both the Marvel
and the DC I guess threads or form
sections over at the weekly pull net
I'll have a link down in the description
for each of them what I want you guys to
do is to go there and I want you guys to
give me your top five choices for your
marvel vs DC battles and so if your top
five is like Batman vs dark side and
rockets Batman vs you know Iron Man and
dark side versus Thanos and so on and so
forth post those down there and so what
I'll do is probably monday night i'll go
through that whole list go through all
those different pages and i will look up
all the different battles that you guys
have chosen and i will pick my top 5
list based on that so this is your
chance to have your voice heard make
sure you guys head over there make sure
you guys check it out and yeah so i'm
looking forward to see what you guys
come up with I will catch you guys later
peace